speaking of cool these North winds are
cool out there gorgeous as we see some
early light now and the Sun is on its
way up shining across the valley this
morning 51 degrees but that's only
because the wind look at this 21 mile an
hour winds sustained right now at the
airport we are 11 degrees warmer but
again it doesn't feel warm because of
the north wind Sunrise officially with 6
26 and 428 is the sunset air is very dry
these North winds always really dry us
out we're mostly 50's some 40s in the
valley and outside the valley almost the
same really a mix of 40s and 50s 20's in
Caliente and Ely in the in the teens
this morning with 20s for Tonopah and
Reno so wind gusts as you can see up in
the mountains over 35 miles an hour
North Las Vegas and many places around
the valley including the airport 30 plus
mile an hour wind gusts Mount Charleston
is going to be Breezy to windy 42 for
the high please take warm coats up there
so developing snow now through the
Rockies it's not too heavy but from
Denver to Albuquerque turkey if you're
traveling you may run into some good
snow there and developing thunder
showers and Rain from Houston all the
way up to Little Rock even eventually
into Nashville today that's where the
rain and could be some slowdowns at
airports if you are flying out in those
areas today high pressure over the West
we should keep lots of good Sunshine see
a couple of high clouds this morning but
those will thin out very quickly and
wind advisories Southern Clark County
and along the river and Southeast
California staying in place until this
evening at six o'clock so our normal
high 63 we're right really where we
should be we're just going to keep these
Breezy to Gusty winds through the
afternoon to dinnertime so kind of cool
and that will feel even cooler with
those winds there but we will we'll have
nice weather through the weekend just
really normal next week much cooler with
50's chance of showers John Monday night
into early Tuesday morning wish it was a
better chance of rain because we sure do
need some more do yeah